hello friends this week I'm sitting down
with dr. Mario Livio he's an
internationally known astrophysicist a
fellow of the American Association for
the Advancement of science best-selling
author and a popular speaker his new
book why
what makes curious is a bit of a
departure away from his previous topics
on physics and astrophysics and it's
really really interesting the field of
curiosity is a lot deeper and more
complex than I thought
curiosity sounds like one word turns out
there is a whole host of very different
and subtle things that all contribute
together to manifest what we consider to
be curiosity so through the lens of the
great Richard Feinman Leonardo da Vinci
and many other famous historic examples
doctor Livia manages to lay out a lovely
landscape Russ to understand curiosity
in this podcast I owe an awful lot for
finding time to come and speak to me I'm
trying to avoid too much public audible
masturbation here while here while they
introduce this particular podcast but
feeling very excited about the next few
months I have booked without a doubt
some of the best minds on the planet to
come on this podcast mr. Jonathan hight
author of the righteous mind is coming
on Rory Sutherland vice chairman of
Google V advertising which is one of the
biggest advertising companies in the
world tiago forte of the Praxis blog
plus an awful lot of other guests that I
can't even talk about yet and on top of
that myself Gianni and Yusuf are doing
our first ever live podcast this week
for communica ristmas conference now
community co-op on smooth fm Capital FM
in a number of different areas along
with a few other broadcasting companies
and for some reason they are allowing us
to sit down in front of all of their
marketing executives this Thursday and
talk about influence the pod casting
platform generally and doing a live Q&A
on stage in front of an audience at the
time side cinema
so although my sphincter is puckering
with the nerves
I'm absolutely buzzing to get stuck in
and hopefully as long as they let me do
it I'll actually be publishing the
podcast live through this channel as
well in the meantime we're going to find
out what makes us curious
here's dr. Livia
[Music]
mario livio welcome to modern wisdom how
are you today thank you
my pleasure it's really good to have you
on so when I was having a look at the
different options to go through for this
podcast with yourself your backlog of
books is it's pretty vast there's an
awful lot that we could have decided to
cover but your most recent book is on
curiosity that's right correct yes
so it's called why what makes us curious
that's a departure from the math maths
and physics based books that you've
published before what's the reason for
this move towards this what what
particular curiosity drove you to write
about curiosity right so indeed it is a
departure I am an astrophysicist myself
and all my previous books were either
about you know physics mathematics
things like that astrophysics I'm
neither psychologist nor a
neuroscientist so indeed this is a
departure but what happened was that I
was always and still am an
extraordinarily curious person and about
five years ago or so a little more I
just became extremely curious about
curiosity itself so I spent the last
five years or so you know reading almost
every article that you know about
research that was done on curiosity in
both psychology and neuroscience I
interviewed the many researchers that
work in this field actually not that
many because not that many work in this
field specifically and I visited some
labs and this resulted in this book is
it - a prodigally quite new ground and
that you've been doing putting the work
of what is curiosity together you said
that that doesn't appear to be a vast
body of knowledge that already exists
was to dis require a lot of work on your
part yes a lot of work on my part I mean
look
let's face it I mean the researchers in
psychology and in neuroscience they do
the real work on curiosity what I have
done was trying to put together you know
some sort of a summary of the type of
work that they have been doing I did
discover that you know some of them are
so immersed in very very specific topics
regarding curiosity that you know
sometimes even they are not fully aware
of the whole picture you know in terms
of the research done in this field so
hopefully my book you know does serve
some purpose of trying to give the
slightly bigger picture even if by a non
specialist I suppose that coming from
outside of the field affords you the
learners mind and allows you to see
everything with a fresh perspective
which obviously means that you're able
to draw from all of the different
subject areas so if we're going to begin
with the book then where does it start
does it begin with what makes us curious
or what curiosity is did you manage to
define curiosity so it starts more with
some sort of a definition but the
definition turned out to be more complex
than I originally thought and it was in
fact psychologist Daniel Berlin who some
years back defined at least four types
of curiosity and I started with that
they are actually by the way more than
the four that we defined but but that is
a good starting point so I started with
that by defining these four types which
I'm happy to explain what they are in
order to you know really get more later
more deeply into what it's one of them
needs absolutely let's fire away yes so
the four types that he described were
perceptual curiosity again the names are
names given by him perceptual curiosity
is the curiosity we feel when
something surprises us or when something
doesn't quite agree with what we know or
think we know or you know when something
is ambiguous we don't know is it that or
is it that think for example I don't
know of some children in some remote
village in Tibet seeing a white person
for the first time
that's perceptual curiosity then there
is epistemic curiosity that's the
curiosity that drives all scientific
research it drives also the best works
of art this is when we really ask why
and try to understand things more deeply
you know everything I've done in
astrophysics was driven by this type of
by epistemic curiosity then there are
two other types Beuerlein actually put
them on on axis you know like like
access in in in mathematics you know so
on the axis that's perpendicular to the
one I just described he put two other
types of curiosity one he called
diversity asti that's maybe the most
common manifestation of that is you know
young people today who are constantly on
their cell phones
checking for text messages basically you
know it's the type of things we do to
ward off boredom and things like that or
you know when somebody is waiting
impatiently to see what the new iPhone
model would look like yeah and then
there is specific curiosity specific
curiosity is curiosity about a very
specific thing you know like who was it
that wrote the dead the old man in the
sea or what was the name of the actress
in the French movie we saw last week you
know and things like that so that's
these are the four types that he
described okay and do those tend towards
particular personality types was there a
correlation that was shown between why
someone may have
a kind of curiosity I think all people
have to some degree all of these four I
mean you know I'm sure you had times
when you try to we were curious about
something very specific you know you
wanted to remember oh what what was it
that we did there and you know at that
restaurant or whatever so that specific
curiosity epistemic curiosity ok
scientists maybe do more of that than
others or researchers of any types
because they really try to answer you
know this how and why questions perhaps
more broadly than others but others also
have times when you know they try to
research something perceptual curiosity
everybody felt I mean everybody was
sometimes surprised by something they
thought they know something and they
turned out to be something else and so
so there is no question that you do that
and diversity of curiosity do you know
this thing you do not to be bored I mean
at this point I mentioned young people
before but in fact we're all like that
now I mean you know you enter any coffee
shop and half the people if not more on
their cell phones checking for things so
yeah so so everybody experiences all
these four types but some may be
experience more of one type than others
yeah I got that I understand is there a
role to each of these types of curiosity
play with in people's lives did you find
anyone who was incredibly proficient in
one area well like I said I mean some
people are more epistemically curious
than others I mean in particular you
know great scientists who devote their
entire life
to research a particular topic they are
very epistemically curious in that
respect so so that of course does define
some types of people I you know I devote
in the book or two chapters to two of
the people
that I regard as being you know perhaps
the most curious people in history one
is Bernardo da Vinci and the other is
physicist Richard Feynman and you know
for example in the case of Leonardo
which is better known perhaps he was
curious just about everything you know
he was interested in every natural
phenomenon of course in the arts in you
know one day he could investigate why
the sky is blue and on another what is
the length of the tongue of the
woodpecker another day you know he was
interested in perspective in painting or
on light and shadow
so really literally every day almost he
was researching something so there
aren't too many people like that quite
like that
there was only one topic by the way
which he wasn't interested and that was
politics
yeah and that was very wise on his part
because I remind you we live with the
same time of the Borgias and they
basically killed everybody who was
interested in politics he on the other
hand managed to get funded by them so
clearly this was very clever on his part
you think that that was a conscious
choice by DaVinci to avoid getting
himself embroiled in a potentially
existential threat vibe by using his
cognitive capacity to actually get stuck
into politics I'm sure it played some
role in that I mean it is also true that
you know history wasn't too interesting
for you compared to other topics but but
yes politics hehe definitely wasn't and
I believe that a conscious choice you
know played a part in that so you
touched on Richard Fineman as well why
is what made him a good case study for
curiosity so look fine month first of
all ok it was an incredible physicist of
course Nobel laureate in physics so
first of all in physics itself in
physics itself unlike many others who
are very focused in a particular field
of research that Feynman worked in
every area of physics you know he almost
didn't prioritize he could one day work
on quantum electrodynamics which you
know is this theory of the subatomic
world and in light and on another he
could work on I don't know the friction
between our shoes in the floor things
like that
so really very very different topics and
they all seemed interesting to him so
that that's one thing but in addition to
that you know he was a bongo drummer
even went to Brazil to study you know
from me he was a an expert in
safecracking
for example was he really in breaking
safes
yes yeah why even at one point he even
here the friend who was Jerry's orthia
who was a painter and he wanted to learn
how to draw so he came to this agreement
with what sort ended you know one week
he would teach Dorothy on physics and
the other week Horton would teach him
how to draw and they did this for about
a year or so so it was even interesting
in drawing he he was interested in
biology he actually spent the whole year
studying with people from the biology
department about things in in biology so
he was again some sort of Leonardo on
the with simply with a much stronger
emphasis on physics that's absolutely
fascinating that I knew Richard Fineman
was a was a very interesting individual
and I've looked into his the Fineman
technique as many of the listeners will
know is one of the particular approaches
that me and some of the other co-hosts
are using to try and remember books and
remember what we learn but I didn't
realize just how broad and how deep is
his curiosity went yeah he basically
said he literally said once you know
that everything is interesting if you go
deeply enough into it that's a very good
way to put it
so what do you think drives people to be
curious is it
we eeveelution arey evolutionarily
programmed to be like this is it more of
a cognitive motivation where we realize
that what's at the end will be rewarding
and worthwhile if we continue to pursue
our curiosities so well first of all
there is no question right that that
curiosity developed as an evolutionary
theory people had to be curious in order
to survive I mean you basically had to
know that you cannot just walk off a
cliff and supposed to you know continue
your life undisturbed so so people
clearly curiosity in itself developed as
an evolutionary tool now having said
that you know we know that there are
huge differences among different people
in their curiosity both in terms of the
things they are curious about and the
intensity of their curiosity so in that
again there have been many studies done
on this in particular studies with
identical twins reared apart which were
done because you know then you can find
all kinds of differences that are not
genetic yes genetic and curiosity like
all psychological traits has a strong
genetic component about it the 50% level
which means you know if your if your
parents were were very curious your
grandparents were very curious you're
likely to be very curious person too so
so about 50% that's that but that of
course leaves the other 50% and the
other 50% is of course determined by
everything around you it determines but
which kind of house you grew up in by
your parents by your siblings by your
teachers in school by your your pastor
at church in what country you you were
born at what time and so on so all of
those things of course determine both
the things you're curious about and
your curiosity that's really fascinating
that it's 50/50 what ran a roughly 50 50
years so did you discover any approaches
which environmentally can encourage the
onset of curiosity is there a curiosity
workout program that we can that we can
put ourselves through to improve that
yes so look I mean my book was
intentionally not written as a how-to
yeah but you know of course I you know
found all kinds of things while while
researching and and there are things
that one can do to enhance curiosity in
particular I'm asked this type of
question you know about what you do to
make your children more curious and
things of that nature so there are some
things you can do one is to ask many
questions the other is to answer
questions but to answer to answer them
in a particular way I'll give you an
example suppose that you know you have a
five year old girl who asks you why I
don't know why birds can fly and we
cannot it's a good question good
question yes and so instead of trying it
straight to answer the question you can
do the following you can say why do you
think that birds can fly and we can not
and the girl may come up with some idea
you know for example she may say oh well
maybe because birds are small and light
and we are big and heavy and we cannot
fly right that's a legitimate answer to
this so so then you would say all year
so so let's see if that's correct
because if this is the reason then that
would mean that there are no birds that
are heavier than us right so you say
okay so let's try
to check if there are birds that are
heavier than us and then you know you
can sit with a girl next to a computer
and try to do a search find out and so
you see by having the conversation going
this way you can encourage a pista
materiality for example another thing
that you can do and actually should do
is that if you want to you know again
try to encourage somebody or you know
enhance their curiosity is to start with
something that they are already curious
about instead of starting with something
that you think they should be curious
about
I'll give you again a couple of examples
let's say in the case of children okay
so suppose you think that children
should know that the earth has gravity
there is such a thing is force of
gravity and grab it make things fall
towards Earth and things like that now
if you take a five-year-old and try to
explain to him or her that from what I
just said that may pour them to tears so
what you have to do you start with
something that you know that this child
is already curious about for example I
mean an example I like to give is that I
don't know if that's true in the UK but
in the US children of five six are all
somehow fascinated by dinosaurs yeah
exactly the same here yeah so so you
start with dinosaurs you know because
they are already curious about this so
we start with dinosaurs holding various
kinds of dinosaurs in this and what they
do when they big and they are small as
if that all that things that they are
really curious about and then you say ah
and you know actually all the dinosaurs
they got extinct actually even we know
why and we even think we know when you
know I mean they got extinct some 66
million years ago and it came because
some large rock and asteroid hit the
earth we even know where it hit
somewhere in the Yucatan Peninsula in
Mexico so and you know why that rock
came to earth because the earth has this
gravity which attracted this rock you
know which then accelerated towards
earth and hit it so you started with
something they are curious about and you
reach that point which you wanted them
to know so that's that's one way the
same applies by the way to adults
suppose you know somebody that is
obsessed with some celebrity I don't
know
taketake some celebrity okay magnus
carlsen just one yesterday the again the
world championship in chess for example
but the huge celebrity but as far as
chess goes he is a celebrity because he
has been now for a good number of years
champion and he defended his title for
the third time okay okay but you know
that this person that you're talking to
is not interested in chess at all is
actually only interested in money so you
start with money you say do you know how
much the world chess champion money how
much money he makes a year and you know
this Perl he or she probably doesn't
know you say well it turns out he has
made eight million dollars last year so
that already makes him somewhat curious
yes and then you can start explaining
you know how come he made this because
he has become a huge celebrity in Norway
his Norwegian
you know every kid knows him yesterday
when he played you know Norway is only
like what such something like five
million people or so about a million of
them were watching the game you know it
things like this so you you start with
the money and get into the chest and the
other things so you begin with something
that has an existing curiosity and then
latch or the curiosity is on to it
that's fascinating so during the
research for the book obviously we've
discussed da Vinci and and Fineman from
the past did you did you get to meet any
exceptionally curious people that are
around today yes well some of them I met
others I spoke to or on the phone or in
Skype or in other ways yes but yes I
actually interviewed well first of all I
you know I met the researchers which
themselves are quite curious the
researchers did to work on curiosity but
I also chose 90 individuals that I
regard as exceptionally curious who live
today and which I interviewed for the
book so I'll give you examples that I'm
sure some of them at least you know so
for example one that I'm convinced you
know is Brian May right I was not
expecting that was not expecting that
name to come out of your mouth
okay so Brian May is the lead guitarist
of Queen of course but you may or may
not know that he's also a PhD in
astrophysics where he actually finished
his PhD more than 30 years after he did
his bachelor's in astrophysics Wow lead
guitarist worth four for a queen but he
was also Chancellor of University
Liverpool he is a world expert in
Victorian stereo photography and he is a
huge activist for rights of animals so
you see I mean he is best known of
course as lead guitarist for Queen
but he has many many other interests in
some of which you know some that require
real work like doing the PhD in
astrophysics he's risen to the top of
his field within a number of fields
there right right so um so so he was one
that I interviewed just to mention a
couple of others again some of them you
may know it some not norm ski is a
famous linguist and you know did a lot
of work on music on the brain is a big
political activist he wrote many many
books and so on somebody that you
probably don't know but I'll mention
something that you probably do know Jack
Horner is a paleontologist from
University of Montana
he discovered much of what we know about
dinosaurs and he was science advisor to
all the Jurassic Park movies but in
addition to this believe it or not is
extraordinarily dyslexic
he can read today at the level of a
second grader and you know when I asked
him but how is it possible I mean you're
such a leading researcher how is it
possible that you know you can hardly
read and he told me you know what when
you do everything first you don't have
to read that much you know so that's
what what was in his case you know he
tried to do everything to be the first
who does that
so yes another person from the UK that
is fairly well known in the UK and if
not should be even more well known
that's Lord Martin Rees he's also
astronomer royal for Britain again a
person who of course did a lot of work
in astrophysics but also
wrote things about risks to humanity in
fact founded a center for risk study has
recently published a book about the
future and so on so again very
interested in many topics so nine people
like that but that's such an eclectic
mix of interests I guess could only be
driven by this furious level of
curiosity a couple of names that some of
the listeners may know and you may as
well who come to mind
brat Weinstein brother of Eric Weinstein
in person well you know so Brett name
Brett is an evolutionary biologist and
Eric who's his brother is the managing
director of teal capital and on his most
recent podcast that he did with Joe
Rogan he went from about as deep
knowledge in cephalopods and octopuses
as I could have imagined to playing the
harmonica to talking about Native
American Native American music how the
the ukulele had moved around different
areas of the world it was such a diverse
range of interests that he'd obviously
taken to the absolute end you know he
knew as much about them in a field as
anyone who was an expert would do and I
think that kind of polymath approach
it's just so interesting to people
nowadays and it must there must be a
complementary mechanism whereby people
who are specialists in one field open up
pathways to become to have greater
understanding in others you know
yourself as a perfect example having
doubled down in physics and astrophysics
for so long permitted you to I'm not
gonna put words in your mouth I doubt
that the book was easy to write by any
means but I'm sure that there were a
number of skills and curiosities which
had aided you from your past in writing
this book in the future that is correct
in particular I mean you know research
and things like this and in the love of
research in fact in all my books the
part that I enjoy the most
actually in writing books is actually
the research part when I do all the
research work because I am sort of by
nature a researcher and that's the part
that I really enjoy I enjoy that more
than the act of writing itself you know
I enjoy studying about all these things
and this is also why by the way my first
book was straight on astrophysics but
all the following five books were all
not precisely on my you know day to day
work because I I decided to work on
things that were somewhat different from
my everyday work because that allowed me
to do more research on them because if
you'd been doing things on your tights
that I work you would have known
everything already yeah my the first
book you know all I had to do basically
is is take my my daily work and try to
put it you know in a language that it
would be understandable for a layperson
but I didn't have to do a lot of
research for that but in all the coming
the following five books I had to do
quite a bit of research on each one of
those books and of course more than most
actually on this last book why what
makes us curious because this was really
outside my field
so you afforded yourself the luxury of
being able to research into new fields I
can draw a little bit of an analogy
there between your profession and mine
so I've been a I've run nightclubs for
12 years and often when I have a night
off my friends will message me and say
oh you're off tonight man like do you
fancy coming out with us and going on a
night out and like no that's not what I
want to do that just feels like me going
back to work yes I understand so during
the writing of the book were there any
real surprises or anything that you
didn't expect to discover which you
which you came across yeah they were
quite a few surprise
I mean first of all I wasn't aware of
these different types of curiosities
that I mentioned you know I thought of
curiosity is one thing but what I
discovered in particular was that there
is a big difference between perceptual
curiosity that's the curiosity when we
are surprised or something you know
doesn't agree with think we now and
epistemic curiosity that's the what
drives research first of all in terms of
the psychological state in which they
put us perceptual curiosity the thing
that surprises us puts it in a state of
unpleasantness in an aversive state and
the curiosity is the mechanism that
tries to get us out of the unpleasant
state that's the way that one works on
the other hand epistemic curiosity
actually puts us in a state that is
pleasant it's a state of an anticipation
of reward you know like when you are
expecting somebody to give you a piece
of chocolate or when you you know see a
movie you wanted to see for a long for a
long time before that so they are very
different in terms of the psychological
state but since we now can also do
research in neuroscience and scientists
have done that meaning they take people
they stick them into functional MRI
machines and they make them curious in a
certain way and they see which areas of
their brain are being activated and what
they discovered was believe it or not
that in the case of perceptual curiosity
the area of the brain that is being
activated is indeed an area that is
associated with conflict and with
unpleasant feelings while in the case of
epistemic curiosity the area that is
activated is the area that's associated
with anticipation of reward so these two
types of curiosity are really different
both in terms of the cycle
logical state in which they put us and
in terms of the area of the brain that
is being activated so I would almost go
so far as say that had we known this
from the start we might have even not
used the same word curiosity for both
types of this curiosity because there
are really different things that's so
different yeah we might have called one
interest in the other I don't know
anxiety or something here yeah totally
so so so this was one thing that that I
didn't know before and therefore it
surprised me I must say I was also a
little bit surprised you see to me
curiosity was a very big thing I mean
like I said because I was always so
curious so I always thought and still
think that you know this drives almost
everything we do I mean you know you
don't read a book unless you're curious
about this you don't see a film unless
you're curious about this you don't
listen to this podcast and unless you're
a little bit curious about this and you
don't even engage in a simple
conversation if you are not a little bit
curious about the topic of the
conversation right so and of course
curiosity drives it ucation elite drives
all the basic research it drives you
know some of the greatest works of art
and all them so to me this was a huge
thing and yet I was surprised that among
psychologists and neuroscientists for
example relatively a small number of
people devote really all their work to
the study of curiosity I guess you know
maybe I and I know more I should have
expected this because the thing is that
people for example who do neuroscience
the field is so vast you know and you
know for example there is a huge number
of them who study how can you help in
the case of Alzheimer's disease you know
things like that and and and so that the
number of people who actually regard
curiosity as their main focus is
relatively not a huge number of people
since that was another surprise for me
it's a subsection of a subsection within
a discipline isn't it I suppose right
it's right so one thing that I've found
quite interesting was the the point on
the the fear that certain types of
curiosity give us and I can think to
fifty thousand years ago 100 thousand
years ago hunter-gatherer tribes out on
the plains and too much curiosity or
seeing something that's new really the
only successful way to interpret that
would be a potential threat because if
you didn't interpret a new or different
looking bush or a new or different
looking animal as a potentials something
to be anxious or fearful about the
chance of you walking over to it and
being killed means you're dead so if if
nature is able to discriminate us away
from that kind of curiosity peeking our
interest to go and look at more we
actually have a better chance of
surviving because if you run away from
the animal and it wasn't dangerous then
you don't really lose anything but if
you go towards the animal and it is
dangerous then you're dead right so you
touched upon the right thing but you you
didn't say at the end the most important
thing which was that it was through
curiosity that you opted actually can
overcome the fear you see because by
learning more about that you are much
less fearful of it so yes you see
something new this puts you into this
surprised mode or you know this
unpleasant mode but then if you're
curious about it you've discover more
about this and that's how you overcome
the fear
so I actually coined this phrase in the
book curiosity is the best remedy for
fear which I'm kind of proud of even
though I discovered I wasn't the first
who formulated something along these
lines so the idea is that we we are
really very often things who are afraid
of our thinks we don't know enough about
or know very little
about I mean this this cause cause all
kinds of you know racial things and and
social things you know and so when
there's a group of people that are
different from you and and in in some
ways and these people as long as you
don't know anything about them you might
be fearful about them if somebody just
you know I mean currently there is
worldwide a big immigration problem
right if somebody would come and tell
you oh well all immigrants are
terrorists then you know this you are
very fearful but once you become a
little bit more curious about this and
then you discover that this seventy year
old woman who is crossing borders with
his three-year-old grandson because -
you know - because she wants to somehow
run away from all kinds of atrocities
she's really not a threat to your she's
not a terrorist
neither is her grandson so by by putting
your curiosity to work by understanding
more by learning more about things you
are much less afraid of that curiosity
oddly is kind of cause and effect in
this situation than to one degree that's
right no it's right so what else were
there any other surprising surprising
revelations that you came across as you
went through the the research for the
book well you know there are surprises
that are associated with particular
people you know when I looked for this
is extraordinarily curious people I mean
you know you mentioned some people that
do a number of things another person for
example that that I interviewed is
fabulous Gino T who is the director
general of CERN it's the European Center
for Nuclear Research she actually led
the group of thousands of scientists who
discovered this subatomic particle the
Higgs boson a few years ago but believe
it or not
the first degree she did in university
was in music and she is an accomplished
pianist to this very day so you know she
really loves music she still plays
listens all the time
to music she is also an avid cook she
loves to cook and she sees similarities
between physics and and cooking there
are certain rules but there is also
creativity so I mean so you know so you
discover all these things about people
you didn't know I interviewed this woman
Marilyn Vos savant she's a person that
actually did not finish even her
undergraduate degree she went for a
couple of years the university but then
stopped but she is the woman with the
highest ever recorded IQ really yeah in
fact the IQ tests don't really even work
when you get to those numbers but how
high was it 228 as a recorded IQ of 220
wait just so that you appreciate that
richard fineman one of the greatest
minds in physics ever is 125 she is
228 and she you know and even though she
has no formal education she knows a lot
she actually has a column in a in a
weekend magazine where she answers
questions in mathematics in logic in
linguistics things like that
and so and so you know again you hit
upon these people that you may have
heard about a little bit but you know
you talk to them and you realize how
interesting this all is it's speaking to
someone with an IQ which is that high
even as someone who is a an accomplished
intellectual like yourself does it feel
a little bit like sort of standing at
the feet of
well yes you know we all stand off
course on the shoulders of giants his
famous Isaac Newton quote you know he
said you know if I if I've seen farther
than others is because I stood under the
shoulders of giant some people claimed
that this was a little bit of an ironic
remark made to who whom he wasn't in
particularly good relation with but
interestingly let me just mention this
as a side remark Brian May whom I did
interview is the person living person
who looks the most like Isaac Newton
just visually if you've ever seen a
picture of Newton yes both the hair and
the nose and thing that it really looks
like Isaac Newton do you think so that
was a you think that was a conscious
choice yeah no I I'm sure his hair had
much more to do with him being a famous
rock guitarist and then with Newton
Isaac Newton potentially could have
taken up a different career if he'd want
her to I kind of doubt it because I
wasn't was uh it was you know one of the
greatest if not the greatest genius to
have ever lived but um it was not
exactly an easy person and and not I
don't think he was a person who sort of
enjoyed life you had some very he had
some very bad traits didn't he didn't he
enjoy going to see hangings and
executions and stuff was not one of his
favorite pastimes I'm not sure that he
did that to be honest but but but he
indeed he did engage in a variety of
debates in in battles with various
scientific adversaries so if you were to
pick a curiosity hero throughout time
have you got one that
that you admire the most so well
Leonardo beats everybody hands-down
Leonardo da Vinci beats everybody hands
down there has not been something like
this neither before nor after I don't
think that I don't think anybody comes
even close
that's a big accolade yes but you know
he deserves it he definitely does so one
thing I want to touch on before we
finished was the the book cover of why I
thought it was very interesting why did
you get why did you get that designed
well you know usually before my book
appears the publisher which is Simon &
Schuster in this case sends me a few
well I take that back they don't
immediately send me a few they send me
one suggestion further cover I don't
know why but almost invariably until now
and this is my sixth book I always
didn't like the first cover that I've
seen and then I say no I don't like that
I would like something different and
then they send me something different
and this was it you know with a huge
question mark in colors on a white
background and the question mark of
course comes under the word why so I
thought that's very fitting I mean you
know why is that what what really is the
sort of essence of curiosity I got that
well Mario thank you very much for your
time I think the topic of curiosity
definitely appears to be one that's a
lot more vast than I would have thought
definitely I agree with you that finding
out that there's different types after
you realize that it's one of those
things that's an aha moment of course
the same kind of curiosity that makes
you wonder wonder about a new landscape
in front of you're a new animal that
you've just seen is not the same one
that makes you want to go and see that
film in the future it's
they serve different purposes and they
work on different mechanisms so it's odd
that something which I wouldn't have
guessed in advance makes so much logical
sense afterwards if that makes if that
holds true yeah I I understand and by
the way I mentioned that there are other
types of curiosity as well for example
morbid curiosity you know the fact that
you get all these rubber necking every
time there is an accident on the highway
right I mean even people on the other
side of the road they slow happen right
yeah yeah that's totally correct well
would you be able to tell the listeners
at home where they can find you online
well I do have a webpage it's Mario my
first name - Lee Viacom there is also a
Wikipedia page about me I do have a
Facebook page and I am on Twitter as
well which is Mario underscore live Y is
my handle fantastic well I will make
sure that all of the links to your
website and your social are in the show
notes below so if anyone wants to get
the book why what makes us curious or
any of you are the work golden ratio or
the entire back catalogue which I feel
like we could have gone on all night to
go through but I really appreciate your
time thank you very much for coming on
thank you for having
[Music]